er fasst wenn putin biograf jetzt sagt
frau strack-zimmermann gerade was
protein möglicherweise als nächstes
vorhaben könnte weil er das ja genau so
kommuniziert hat sie haben die
biographien schauen sie in seinen kopf
was wird er machen in den nächsten
wochen in den nächsten monaten wird er
sich zufrieden geht es um ost ukraine
hat wird er aufhören wird dass der staat
sein für eine verhandlungslösung oder
holt er sicher weise bis zum grund
seines kopfes schaue ich auch nicht ja
auch wenn ich in ziegelstein über den
mann geschrieben habe aber eins eins
weiß ich für den ist zum beispiel große
differenz zu hitler er kommt ja leider
oft in so soll dieses populistische
argumente und putin werden nebeneinander
gestellt putin hat keine
langfristige vision von der besessen ist
die hat dann nie gehabt
wiederherstellung der sowjetunion und
auch nicht die vernichtung der
ukrainisch kennen artikel aus dem juli
letzten jahres sehr sehr gut im detail
auch im russischen analysiert putin ist
und deswegen haben angelsachsen sehr
frisch und dieses urteil gefällt er
spielt sehr gut mit schlechtem blatt
blut in ist ein meister der der stadt
des strategischen opportunismus er passt
seine ziele immer seinen möglichkeiten
an und er macht fehler dabei und diese
fehler immer das habe ich auch in meiner
biografie analysiert mit der ukraine zu
tun einer der der größte fehler war
wahrscheinlich seine möglichkeiten am 24
februar so miserabel falsch
einzuschätzen aus welchen gründen auch
immer dass er in diesen schlamassel
geraten ist den er jetzt will aber er
hat seither schon gezeigt dass er eben
seine seine möglichkeiten seine ziele
seine möglichkeiten anzupassen weiss und
das wird er auch weiterhin tun
die armee ist mittlerweile
runtergekommen frau statt immer man
formuliert über ein bisschen ein
bisschen ähnlich ist nur die bilder die
im moment um die welt gehen zeigen das
gegenteil eine stadt nach der neuen es
fehlt an
stefan krause kommen sie nicht frau
stark zimmermann jetzt eine extreme
erklärungsnot in den nächsten wochen
dass sie beweisen müssen dass diese
waffen liefern auch die deutschen die
auf geringem niveau stattgefunden haben
die internationalen waffenlieferungen
überhaupt was bringen also inzwischen
hat deutschland nach langer diskussion
nicht nur geringen niveau beigetragen
sondern ordentlich dazu beigetragen
beispiel panzerhaubitze wo es auch noch
weitere geliefert werden die sehr sehr
wirkungsvoll sind das wird uns auch aus
der ukraine bestätigt und das ist ein
kampf der artillerie die mit artillerie
beantwortet wird und zwar auf eine
längere distanz wir gehen weiter und
sagen wir könnten uns auch vorstellen
dass der schutz und kann zwei bagger
eingesetzt wird in der tat wäre man dann
näher würde man sich dann näher umgeht
dann eine stadt nach der nächsten
verloren hat das ist das tut sie ja
nicht gut an dass das tut sie ja nicht
sondern wir sehen natürlich die bilder
die uns vermittelt werden wir sicher
nicht tagtäglich da dass die städte die
angegriffen werden komplett zerstört
werden also dieses diese lust des
zerstörers und zwar koste es was es
wolle diese städte verschwinden gerade
die ukraine sein riesiges land und da
ist uns ist ein so großes land das
natürlich nicht alle städte verschwinden
aber natürlich ist die mediale
aufmerksamkeit das machen sie ja auch
konzentrieren sich natürlich auf diese
dramen der städte wo das eben der ost
ukraine besonders dramatisch ist diese
städte verschwinden gerade aber die
ukraine ist groß und da ist noch mehr
was es zu verteidigen aber das land herr
krause was im moment verloren geht jetzt
ist es eben dieses lied ernst was so
lange wir so lange umkämpft war um
kesselt war aus der stadt dass der auch
paul ronzheimer so intensiv berichtet
hat und jetzt sehen wir heute die
meldung ist diese stadt gefallen wieder
linie ist die ganze region lohans
mittlerweile an die russische armee
warum halten wir dass da nicht auf wenn
das so wichtig ist wenn uns die ukraine
so felix warum halten wir das dann nicht
auf das können sie das ist eine ganz
einfache antwort auf die russen haben
dort im blick eine solche übermacht an
artillerie die können wir auch nicht
durch mit chili lieferungen brechen aber
die russen verbrauchen pro tag bis zu
50.000 geschützt munition das können sie
auf die dauer nicht aushalten und die
ukraine wissen dass sie haben eine sehr
intelligente taktik das heißt sie lassen
die russen schießen lassen sie kommen
beschissener die infanterie lieder
wieder weg läuft weil die russische
infanterie ziemlich schwach ist sie
versuchen zu taktieren sie versuchen
sich zurückzuziehen wie der unseren zu
fassen also das ist sozusagen vom
militärischen her gesehen gar nicht mal
so dumm was die ukraine machen sie
versuchen aus dem was sie haben das
beste zu machen und sie waren relativ
erfolgreich gegen diese walze die seit
dem seit mitte april auf sie zurollen
wie gesagt zehn wochen lang dieser jury
walze und erfolg gerade mal 200
quadratkilometer hat das ist nicht viel
an perfekt ich diese stadt nach der
anderen